[Música]
segundo bloque de economía en directo
América Daniela Blandón me acompaña
nuevamente Dani vamos a hablar por
supuesto de Rusia que le pide a las
empresas que se queden en el país Claro
que sí Raúl y es que el kremlin
reconoció que se enfrenta a su situación
más difícil en tres décadas debido a las
sanciones occidentales sin precedentes
pero advirtió que los intentos
extranjeros de aislarla de la economía
mundial van a fracasar escuchemos
Tribuna quiero dirigirme individualmente
a las empresas extranjeras desde estas
gradas a las que todavía están pensando
en irse y a las que quieren quedarse a
trabajar en nuestro país Rusia sigue
abierta al diálogo constructivo
respetamos su trabajo y su esfuerzo para
invertir en proyectos en nuestro
territorio pero si se ven obligados a
irse sus empresas tienen que continuar
con su labor aquí porque nuestros
ciudadanos están trabajando allí la
protección de sus intereses es nuestra
prioridad el nivel de la vida de las
personas no puede depender de los
Caprichos de los políticos extranjeros
vamos entonces a dejar un vistazo a las
más recientes sanciones claro es que de
occidente está intensificando otra vez
la imposición de castigos al kremlin
después de descubrir la ejecución de
civiles en la ciudad de bucha
supuestamente cometida por el ejército
Ruso y ahora tocan el lado familiar de
Vladimir Putin Estados Unidos se excluyó
del sistema financiero y les congeló los
activos en ese país a dos hijas del
presidente caterina y María
acusa de esconder la riqueza de su padre
también apuntó a los bancos es verbank y
Alfa Bank y prohibió a los
estadounidenses invertir en la nación
exótica Europa también está analizando
medidas como vetar el carbón Ruso y en
un futuro no cercano no cercano analizar
si puede hacer lo mismo con el petróleo
y con el gas también quieren prohibir
los barcos los rusos en sus puertos y
algunas exportaciones de alta tecnología
bueno Dani también el aumento de los
precios menores del trigo está
directamente relacionado con todo este
conflicto y por qué Porque Rusia y
Ucrania pues son responsables de una
tercera parte del suministro mundial de
este cereal y en este momento los
agricultores tienen dificultades para
plantar sus cosechas por los intensos
combates mientras que la escasez de gas
natural agrava mucho más su situación
los detalles en el siguiente informe
conduciendo lejos de miko Life las
tierras de cultivo del Sur del país se
pueden ver desde la carretera ahora
transformadas en campos de batalla los
misiles están enterrados en el suelo
mientras que los restos de los
helicópteros rusos ensucian los campos
en general los combates han dificultado
el trabajo de los agricultores
ucranianos
los rusos no paraban de disparar
constantemente disparaban era terrible
si bien este campo de trigo fue plantado
el mes de noviembre no es el caso de las
demás parcelas que aún no han sido
sembradas
todavía tenemos que plantar otros Campos
como los girasoles con máquinas Y eso se
hace entre el 15 y el 20 de abril para
ello necesitamos combustible y semillas
sin embargo la gasolina está relacionada
en Ucrania y aquí
los tanques de combustibles están vacíos
Ucrania es el quinto exportador mundial
de trigo aquí están las principales
regiones agrícolas del país muchas de
las cuales se ven afectadas actualmente
por los en curso por esta razón el
gobierno ucraniano Espera que la
producción de trigo caiga un 30% este
año y ese no es el único problema
[Música]
estos son los hilos de grano del puerto
de nikola Life donde se exporta gran
parte del trigo del país nadie ibanova
tiene trigo cosechado del año pasado
almacenado aquí pero no puede venderlo
porque el puerto está completamente
cerrado
debido a la guerra ya no tenemos acceso
al mar Negro los barcos de la armada
rusa bloquean las entradas y salidas es
muy arriesgado desde el comienzo de la
guerra los precios de tirgo van
aumentado un 70%. lo que hace temer la
escasez de alimentos en algunas partes
del mundo
Dani Y también tocamos otro tema porque
la reserva Federal de Estados Unidos se
puso agresiva en qué sentido pues Raúl
hay un documento que el mercado todos
los meses se espera con muchas ansias y
son las minutas de la Fed esas detallan
las decisiones de la más reciente
reunión de junta directiva pero también
da luces sobre lo que viene a
continuación y todo parece indicar que
en los próximos meses la Fed se
inclinará por subir los tipos de interés
de forma más agresiva las tasas
oficiales hoy están en un Rango de entre
0,25% Y 0,5%. estuvieron dos años
ancladas en niveles cercanas al 0% para
contener los efectos sobre la economía
que dejó la pandemia de todas maneras si
lo comparamos con otros países es un
nivel pues bajo relativamente porque
mire en Colombia la tasa de interés ya
está en el 5% en México está en el 6,5%
que son mucho más que el
0.5%, qué dolor las tarjetas de crédito
cuando lleguen el mes que viene sí señor
indicadores económicos
los resultados mezclados en las
diferentes bolsas del mundo con pérdidas
significativas en Asia tras conocerse
justamente estas intenciones futuras de
la reserva Federal no es así en Europa
que opera con ligeras ganancias Aunque
todavía los ojos están puestos sobre la
guerra y sobre la pandemia y para
finalizar este último bloque económico
del día la cifra 1,6 billones de dólares
pues se estima que los unos 43 millones
de estudiantes estadounidenses tienen
créditos federales por este valor y la
noticia es que los pagos de estas
obligaciones estaban congelados desde
hace más de dos años y hasta finales de
este mes y la administración de Joe
biden acaba de extender ese plazo hasta
el 31 de agosto una buena noticia
Daniela que ojalá también los gobiernos
de nuestra región y nuestro continente
América Latina del Caribe pues tomen
para pues así ayudar a estos estudiantes
que están saliendo de estudiar con estas
grandes deudas Y seguramente muchísimos
de ellos lamentablemente no tienen un
trabajo para poder así cumplir este
compromiso del pago de esta deuda cierto
sobre todas las tasas de interés en
Estados Unidos ya están en el 0% para
estos créditos precisamente y en otros
países son altísimas
bueno Dani muchísimas gracias entonces
nos vemos mañana con más economía aquí
en directo América y la despido para
darle la bienvenida a Omar está con los
deportes